once upon a time Zack Snyder was an
aspiring director who wanted to show
people that he could make a movie and he
did he gave us this dawn of the dead.the
remake
now I give George a Romero's all the
credit in the world for givin a zombie
movies as we know them and even zombie
movies in general but Zack Snyder's
remake of Dawn of the Dead just seemed
to up the intensity for me and that's
why I really like it now if you've seen
the original Dawn of the Dead or play
the game Dead Rising you pretty much
know what you need to know about this
movie the world is ending zombies are
spreading like a wildfire so a handful
of people waiting them all to outweigh I
don't know the apocalypse actually
sounds kind of boring when you say it
like that but it's really not it's cool
now this movie has a pretty impressive
plethora of people I mean all sorts of
people in this movie you got that normal
people you got the prick the [ __ ] the
sleazy guy the hot chick it even has
lawyers in the movie only they're the
ones outside the mall oh and for the
most part you like the characters even
the dude with the crazy chat mustache
man he's an [ __ ] at the beginning but
I mean by the end you end up like kind
of liking him he was like my favorite
character and you have a small group of
people they're holed up in them all four
weeks what do you do
Oh have the guy across the street with
the rifle pop shots at the zombies while
you watch yeah I'm not gonna lie that's
what I would do is exactly what I would
do and the zombies and under the Dead
like 28 days later do not walk like
senior citizens with hip replacements no
they haul ass after you of the zombie
dreams that we guys have loved and
secretly want to happen Zack Snyder's
remake of Dawn of the Dead most
accurately depicts mine except for the
creepy ass baby zombie birth scene that
seemed I I don't dream that [ __ ] for
some odd reason to creeps me out if
you're having an onslaught of just
Halloween movies this weekend Donna the
deads got to be on there because there
will be a lot of scenes where you and
your friends will be like oh dude it
says scene dude check it out the scenes
awesome no here it is I mean it's
zombies you don't watch it for some
deeper meaning and it did not win an
Oscar all I know is there were a hundred
and one reasons this movie should have
sucked I should have hated it my friends
and I all walked out of the movie we
were like that movie was badass so I
would say Dawn of the Dead is zombie
tastic ah again because what can I say
it's Halloween you just can't have too
many zombie movies now can you so I say
check out Zack Snyder's Dawn of the Dead
and stay tuned tomorrow for my next
Halloween movie review Kent
yeah sure why not can't rain all the
time and if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more than click
right here to see more